on the hill for your san diego padres is
craig stamin making his first start of
the season's 35th appearance versus
these philadelphia phillies fourth start
versus the phillies this is lying to
center field and a base hit for herrera
grisham will get it back in quickly but
a lead-off single starts the first
inning for the phillies padres double
play depth in the middle and this could
be two
stamina second for one on the first for
two double play
there you have it he induced it right
back at him and stamin fields his
position very well
and ground ball into the shift that is
machado in right who throws him out
so it's a 5-3 with the shift and eight
pitch inning for stamen kyle gibson gets
the ball today eight and five overall
two and two with a 4.70 era since
joining the fills trent grisham leading
it off
02 is a fly ball to right field harper
on the run going back it's gonna one off
the wall
over to play it is jankowski but
standing in second base with a double
this trent grisham a good start to the
bottom of the first for the padres
and now up come the big guys fernando
tatis jr
on the ground up the middle that'll get
into left center for a base hit grisham
was headed back to second he wasn't sure
two second goes tatis with the throw
going to third sure why that went to
third base on the throw but fernando
goes to second base without a problem
second and third nobody out for machado
fly ball headed to left field herrera is
over
grisham's getting ready herrera makes
the catch so is tatise he's gonna try to
take third run scores and he gets to
third
padres take a one-nothing lead a sac fly
for manny machado san diego strikes
first today the ball is two strikes the
o2 ground ball softly hit towards
shortstop dd's got it and he throws it
across
well padre is going to run but a nice
job by kyle gibson to limit the damage
jt rail muto will lead off against craig
stamen 2-2
bouncer
left side of the infield and chronoworth
airmails it jt thought about it but
it'll head back to first
and the three-two pitch
ball four
swinging them in sand stamen strikes out
grigoris he needed that first strikeout
of the day for craig stamen one down
on the ground left side cronoworth will
go to second base for one on to first
it'll be off the mark
they do get the middleman retiring
hoskins at second base for out number
two
therese will reach it first as romeuto
takes third
on the ground right side ranging is
frazier his throw from the outfield will
get there nice play from adam frazier
good rangy play
look like for sure the fillers are gonna
get a run out of this they do not but
it's thanks to the defense and the glove
of adam frazier ryan weathers is back
out to work he'll face rhys hoskins 3-0
pitch and rhys swings and drives one in
the air out to dead center field grisham
will turn and just watch this one fly
a solo home run for reese hoskins
and we're tied up at one
instant offense right there pat and he's
making his presence known immediately
3-0 fastball
dead down the middle and rhys hoskins
does exactly what he's supposed to do
with it and he crushes it to left center
field one down here's the reyes one two
pitch line drive into right field a base
hit for thereas
one two pitch served in the air out to
right field a base hit for jankowski a
real nice piece of hitting by jankowski
right there
gets it down over to third machado
onto first two outs gotta tell you that
is a superb job right there phil's
threatening here two on two out for
odouble herrera 3-2 pitch ground ball
sharply hit through into right field to
base it one runner will score jankowski
is coming to the plate he'll score as
well it's a two-run single for o'dubo
herrera and the phils take a 3-1 lead
here in the fourth he gets a fastball
3-2 surprise that he goes fastball right
right here with the base open
leaves it out in the middle of the plane
again
really interesting that they would try
to come in in a situation where
a left-hander can do some damage and oh
double takes advantage of it
new pitcher in this game oh right-hander
miguel diaz comes on
swinging a miss and he strikes out so
miguel diaz with the strikeout first k
of his day
in there for strike three good pitch
fastball seemed to fool him he must have
been looking for something else that's
two down two outs and nobody on for
hoskins he homer last inning
one two pitch and re swings and sends
this one in the air out to left field
forget about it
it's a multi-home run game for reese
huskins
now diaz has been throwing some
excellent change-ups but he left this
one
up in the love zone because reese
hoskins jumped all over it and crushed
it to the left and
you talk about that instant offense man
that's exactly what we were talking
about right there double action home run
hap 4-1 phillies on top gibson back out
to work hung on grounded past the mound
not hit hard gene's got it close to
first and cronenworth is retired for the
first out
popped up right side first baseman rhys
hoskins sunglasses on secures out number
two
up the middle and from short gregorius
it's an easy inning for kyle gibson who
is getting better as this game goes on
as a five-pitch inning it's 4-1 philly
takes us to the seventh and a double
herrera to lead it off duo pitch and
o'dubo lifts it in the air out to center
field grisham back towards the wall and
it's gone
oh dubo herrera to dead center field he
has homer in back-to-back games
and the phillies take a 5-1 lead
wow another huge home run right here by
the phillies and oduno herrera has been
swinging the bat really well and doing a
nice job out of that one hole
he crushes this fastball
right down broadway and he does not miss
it
[Applause]
three two down low harper works a walk
here's real muto one ball and no strikes
lifts it out to right field going back
tatis to the wall he'll turn and watch
it fly
an opposite field two-run home run for
jt real muto
and the phillies take a 7-1 lead
well and that is a terrific sign not
only the result but also where he hit
this ball it's been a while since jt has
driven the ball to the right side and
that's when he's making his money
diving in short right in the shift is
the padres third baseman only he's in
right field and he's manny machado
well he got him out there on the shift
so he can do things like that machado
going to his right takes full advantage
of his defensive positioning and makes
an outstanding defensive play to bring
the top of the seventh inning to a close
kyle gibson gets back to work 95 pitches
first pitch to grisham
and he grounds it right to the first
baseman luke williams
and the 2-2 pitch
line drive out to center field
jankowski's got it two away
round ball
right to ronald torrez across the
diamond and another one two three inning
for kyle gibson his fourth consecutive
in the phillies head to the ninth with a
seven one lead
sectorville come on try and record one
final out 53 appearances
down the left field line this ball is
falling and it is falling fair
it will rattle around and clear the
bases it appears
running through the stop sign is
carrottini he'll get in through run
score
and it's 7-4 here come the padres
the one-two
swinging in a miss he got him
hector naris comes in and slams the door
in this ball game and the phillies win
it 7-4
[Applause]